we turn to our phone line right now our
guest line and it is our good friend
from the Tennessee Titans entering is
six season in the National Football
League coming up this fall he's our
buddy
Taylor little on how are you Taylor I'm
good rich but please don't disrespect me
at seven seasons I'm going in my seventh
season is that right
14 15 so yeah that's your seventh seed
well has it started yet but you're going
to your seventh season no disrespect you
are number 77 so I guess it's all it's
all part of a full circle of life thing
going on here
your boy will Compton gets really pissed
at me when I say it's your podcast and
not a co-host right though busting with
the boys with you and will Compton how
often EU are you doing the pod these
days Taylor well I'm actually on
California right now I'm in Encinitas
California so I'm slowly but surely
making my way up to you but I'll pop in
three-four days at a time and we'll do
about anyone six to eight pods right and
I got to be honest Leah rich I got to be
honest my back is sore it's sore from
carrying will as much as I have but
we're going to keep rolling so do you
know what my requirement is to appear on
your podcast correct Taylor yep and it's
not gonna work out but I'll tell you
what should happen is um if anybody was
listening who doesn't you know never
dated Rich Eisen show yes sir
rich said that if the bus is not running
he will not go on the bus however yes we
found loopholes because we're bar still
now we're getting the band rich Oh cuz
it was seventy seven thousand dollars
something about seven to fix my entire
bus no lights not worth it
so that is now going to be a vintage
piece and our shed forever
and we're very proud of it so they're
taking a creative van okay a VW bus
maybe and we're making the la tour March
22nd to the 25th okay you better believe
you're my first guess in the list Wow
so here's a deal so I'm just trying to
figure out so barstool is breaking off a
piece of like big cat and PF tees
residuals and and giving it off to you
to find an actual moving vehicle or is
it the same thing I mean we're not big
timers we're just gonna rent it for now
right yeah I mean wait I mean barstool
personal in us we worked out an
agreement okay
coming out of both pockets but I feel
like overall if you do the performance I
know you can give we're gonna make up
you know how I feel about you Taylor
I'll be there I'll be there and of
course I just need to get some video of
what is under the hood that's all I need
to say cuz again if you haven't fair
enough it's always said if you're gonna
have a podcast based on a moving vehicle
it's got to be able to actually move so
I'm glad to hear that
I just wanted to get that out of the way
at first we started how else's life is
what else is going on with you in your
life what is life like for you here in
early March well early March I'm lucky
enough to be in California I'm trying to
stay away from the corona virus right
now as we all are trying to stay safe
right
but I'm staring down at the ocean right
now I've got my kid and my wife here and
life's pretty good I'm just I'm just
hanging out working out and getting
ready for the next season it's kinda
it's a 24-hour job right 24/7 you're
always constantly thinking about right
what's next you know hold what equal can
you do to you know kind of stay keep an
edge in the competition and new workouts
and so I'm going to XS like I always do
and working with Roy home and trying to
figure out the next next step for me to
take and so it's it's exciting stuff I
love doing this and I haven't gotten
sick of it yet so hopefully I got
another seven years left in me after
this okay well then let's let's get to I
guess some orders of business how are
you going to vote on the CBA
on Thursday Taylor would you share that
with us but I'm pretty sure a very
inappropriate - okay okay right I didn't
vote yes so go ahead and turn it okay
here it out from there okay but I mean
I'm not a I'm not a strongly against nor
for I mean it's the I think there's a
lot more people that are more dialed
into the CBA than I am right and but I
will say I do think it's gonna pass you
do watch I feel that way some of the
very few things I know about this
business CBA is going to give I use this
term very loosely because I don't mean
any disrespect of the lower like lower
tier guys who are like you know between
years one and year five and we're kind
of bouncing the team team those guys
gonna get bumps and the minimum pay yes
and those guys make up a large
percentage
of our CBR of the NFL players yes a lot
of two dozen players there they're more
than 51% so for them to look at say oh
I'm gonna make $100,000 more this year
why wouldn't they vote YES on that so I
think it's a short-term fix for a
long-term issue but but that's as far as
I can really take it because I'm not as
educated as I probably should be well I
mean just in terms of other teammates of
yours
I guess if it was inappropriate to flat
out ask you how you personally voted do
you have you gotten a sense of just in
general other players or either
teammates or around the NFL how they're
leaning on this subject because this is
a pretty damn big vote that we're gonna
hear about on Thursday the results for
yeah I think um I mean I've talked to a
couple guys in the team and some guy
said like you know some guys go to know
some guys voted yes it just is what it
is and everyone has a good reason why
they did or didn't it's just it's a hard
situation to go through because there's
I mean just like America right there's
this there's the there's so many
different levels of income when it comes
to the NFL and people are gonna be
affected differently all the time right
and so it's tough to really get a hold
and grasp this is perfect for everybody
will at the end of day like it's not
going to be great for everyone it's
gonna be great for some guys some guys
any more money some guys are gonna be
you know not gonna do much force and
then in three I believe it's three years
from now we're playing 17 games which is
yeah what's your thought very what's
your thought about that watch it what's
your the I we mentioned tall task so I
can kind of guess where you would go in
the response to this next question what
what is your thought on the subject of a
17th game Taylor the one well I mean I
love I love playing football and I'm
trying to be politically opposed
political as possible rich I hope you
can understand no III cyan it's a very
excellent opening statement for where I
think this is gonna go next to be honest
with you
perfect I I love I really I really do if
I didn't like playing it I would
honestly stop that promise it's I know
how my body feels after 16 games and I
mean I know how my body feels that
they're playing the AFC Championship
asses
you know I missed a few games last year
but after 12 games and three sets 15 you
know what I'm saying I do a it's hard it
is tough and like I think they're taking
out a preseason game which I mean some
guys don't even play three preseason
games you know I'm saying like some guys
you know suit up for the third preseason
game and then they move on and they go
to the season so it's not that much of a
dramatic I'll help you out type of thing
but I mean it's a lot you know I mean I
know it's going to help a lot with
revenue and I understand why the owners
are going the way they are with that and
wanting more games to hell if I was an
owner I want 40 games but it's just it's
hard to keep up with your body for you
know 16 games it was hard in college
keep it up for 12 games and now you jump
up to 16 and now you're hitting 17 so
it's it's a tall order
you know I guess III think there was
something in the CBA at first were guys
weren't even get the same check that
they were making before so if I'm making
you know $10 per game let's just say
like well we get that 17 game I would
make two and a half dollars instead of
ten like well why don't you just in case
let's just keep it the same all the way
through so if that would sound a
relatively make more sense to me and Sam
of course no now what do you think about
it rich no I'm I'm an old school guy I
don't want any more games I think it's
perfect I don't think it should be
touched but then again I'm that's true
but but this is a world in which
everybody needs to make as much as money
as possible whether it's you whether
it's my network whether it's me through
and I found that work whether I'm gonna
be very I'm very honest whether it's the
owners I mean in order to do that you've
got to enhance the product for a
broadcast injury the industry that's
getting stretched every single day for a
dollar and and in terms of that you know
to enhance it with a 17th game and two
playoff teams that one year might
actually go on a run and another year
have no business being in the playoffs
taking away a bye week for a team that
just won the Super Bowl for instance
from the two spot you know you asked me
straight up I'm not a big fan of it but
I'll tell you what though when it comes
down to sitting down and watching that
I guess either a Monday night playoff
game for wildcard weekend or Sunday
night playoff game or Sunday early
afternoon playoff game I'm watching it
on playoff weekend that's for sure I'll
admit it yeah a million percent on well
I mean I suppose definitely turned into
a Americas game and I know baseball fans
really mad at that but it really is
that's what's come I mean people love
football it's a bunch of gladiators
going at it and beating the hell out of
each other and I mean who wouldn't want
to watch that you know however it's
tough I mean correct me if I'm wrong but
in the old the CBA before 2011 there
were less games with six teams right
well there was like 14 games well yeah I
mean back in back in the days of like
Bob Griese and Joe Namath yeah there
were 14 games and then expanded 16 and
then we're you know obviously we've seen
how incredibly popular this sport has
become so sometimes less is more and I
can understand a 17th week might might
be of interest to television networks
and if that raises your cap all the way
through to what like 300 million bucks
one day or 400 million I mean maybe
everybody shares in it again I'm not
fully well-versed on it either to be
very honest that's why I got Joe banner
coming on and our number two to try and
explain it to me the well hold the film
TVs all those concerts are coming up
right after this right so it would be
the NFL owners best interest to probably
get those done and makes things and
makes things easier to get done as far
as like TV deals when you already have
those cba locked up and all that and
you're right I mean if that one could
help you help out the other if the
players sign this one then our tab could
go up to the numbers you were just
talking about that that could be a huge
benefit for us eventually
today although on here on the Rich Eisen
show and then there's a pretty big next
week and a half potentially for for the
future of your team
staying as as as the intact if you will
when was the last time you spoke to Ryan
Tannehill sir I spoke to Ryan about two
weeks ago he was giving me a call when I
was on my way to a workout just and you
know what nicest guy in the world just
to check in see how things were going
but when it comes to that kind of stuff
I don't ask them questions right because
it's a it's a tough situation to be in
and it's a this is a this is a good
situation good problem for John to have
as a GM we had a lot of great football
player
our team and we've had a lot of success
this season we hope to continue that
however you just want I mean you
obviously want everybody to stay because
you love them right and there you do
gain relationships with you guys I love
Tannehill I love Derek Henry uh Logan
Ryan those types of dudes I love them so
it's uh it's a tough situation but the
other day like it's gonna get done the
way it's supposed to get done and all
those guys are going to be paid
handsomely what in the world was it like
watching Derek Henry just truck people
from your position
what in the heck was that well it's
absolutely terrifying I thought the
other side was assault every single time
I mean what watching him run watching my
favorite part about watching Derek Henry
is watching guys like Earl Thomas who I
have so much respect for I respect the
hell out all he is but for him to say
what he said and then ironically getting
shoved and turned into a lead blocker
for him on one of those plays it's I
mean that's just Derek man he is he
doesn't talk a lot in the field he
hardly talks at all he gets mad at me
for because this is his personality
during games during the week he's a nice
guy in the world but I would I mean you
can you can make fun of these DVS and
these linebackers for you know shine
away when he's coming down the pike but
if I'm being honest my 310 self I polish
I label this year did you I mean so what
do you mean he gets mad at you what do
you mean by that
like they're generally super happy guy
loves it and there's a couple plays
where I got to help out the guard it but
also get my guy and then so I know that
Derek's got my outside on certain place
there's one but it comes to mind we're a
firm rule of not talking scheme but I
always if we refer to play a time out
like Garrett you you know you've got my
outside and it hopefully helps stop me
before I can finish the sentiment
Sidney's like just RDL get the victim I
got you all right calm down Taylor just
calm down and then I get insulted
because don't tell me to calm down
and there's like a whisper it we're
having to go whispering match like the
other guys right what's bringing the
huddle at each other no you calm down
you calm down and the Ben Jones got to
get in the middle so it it's uh I mean
it's a band of chaos but for some reason
it's organized chaos and I don't think I
mean I've never been a part of a
different locker room but guys that
leave our locker room
you always seem to come back or text us
and say how great our locker room is and
right it's awesome there
the Titans definitely have a great
locker room they're doing a good job of
putting good character guys in there
that all mesh really well well the coach
helps too I had him on we an NFL Network
had him on at the combine it was great
having a variable on and in terms of it
the Super Bowl we had Derrick Henry on
the show and you know I asked him
specifically if he was aware it was Earl
Thomas who he was stiff-arming and then
shoving in the back for good measure
after Earl said what he said about the
Patriots turning down be an opportunity
to take him down and that the Ravens
wouldn't do the same asked Henry
point-blank if he was aware if it was
tell Thomas at the time Thomas there's
no way you don't know especially watch
the interplay watch Derek stare and take
that man's soul it was demonic I know it
was it was terrifying I needed an old
priest in a young priest just to make
sure everybody was safe after that play
because and again Earl's going in the
Hall of Fame and I have nothing but the
highest respect for him but then but
that's part of the reason why you know
what if what Henry does is so remarkable
I know you wanted to come on and talk
about your your football community and
how it is trying to heal in the
aftermath of the hurricane I mean the
tornado I give you the floor on on that
Taylor what can you tell me I mean so I
was actually in national my wife and I
flew in that Saturday before the tornado
had on Monday and it's I've never been a
part of a tornado in myself growing up
in Arizona you don't have to deal with
those types of things and right
I mean it's devastating what happened to
the people in Nashville the people that
were directly affected but what's even
more remarkable than that there's all
the people there are literally people on
hold for help lines because there's too
many people out there they can't send
enough people out in the city of
Nashville to go help everybody else and
I'm not just talking about Nashville I'm
talking about north of Nashville and
everything everything I was directly hit
people have absolutely come and answered
the bell when it comes to just kind of
pain here of your neighbor
which I think we can all use a good
lesson in and Nashville is a community
that the foundation of it makes you want
to be a part of it for a lifetime
and the fact that these people have come
and done that is unbelievable so my bus
with the boys and barstool was on this
at 5:00 in the morning after everything
happened they they made a t-shirt that's
so strong that we're selling on our
website bussing with the boys calm or
obviously barstool you can go to
commercial air and every single dollar
that is that people pay for for the surf
and my daughter's young it's all good
man I love it I love it it's music to my
ears I'm sure it's uh you know maybe
different to you but it's all good
brother it's awesome well I tell you
anybody who buys that t-shirt every
single dollar they spend it go to the
people that were directly affected yeah
yeah the Titans are gonna be this link
for the community foundation of Middle
Tennessee CF MT org is where you can go
to make it just a simple donation
straight into the community as well as
obviously purchasing the merchandise
from from bussing with the boys CF MT
org is another way that people can can
take part yeah absolutely and I think um
I've been talking to John Robinson and
my kraebel and some of the Predators
guys and a few people in Nashville and I
believe I at this point right now I
think April 29th which is a Wednesday
we're gonna have a slow pitch beer
league softball game at the sound
stadium obviously people can go and buy
tickets when everything is all set up
but once that's all done all the money
that we raised from that is going to go
to to the people directly affected as
well so we're doing the most we can our
owner
Amy out of strung she went donated a
million dollars I know a few other
people donated hundreds of thousands of
dollars so the relief is growing and
growing but there's never enough help in
this world the more you can do not just
for people that were affected by the
tornado but just for people on the
street that are you know panhandling
hope asking for a few dollars down to
luck it is you got nothing to do with us
how they got in that situation it's not
our we can't judge them for it all we
can do is just give them a hand up not a
handout and so you know helping somebody
out after that
except to them what they do for with it
and I think it's all our duty is not
just American citizens but people in
this world I mean we got to stop
thinking of ourselves as oh I'm in the
NFL so I'm better than X Y & Z it's
we're all people and whatever religion
you believe in we are all we are all
equal in some sort of way and we deserve
to help each other out every step along
the way love you Taylor luan you're good
people man let's let's all make this
world a better place go take care of
that daughter of yours you got to be
father of the year too on top of
everything yeah I'm doing my best effort
you having me on you got it we made it
through the entire conversation without
me asking you with Tom Brady question
how about that yeah there it is well
we'll find out March 8 2010 your self
Taylor
you be well have a go I will see you
soon bye Aloha making its way to Los
Angeles with will Compton